du vin pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
vous avez raison de dire que les banques
françaises sont beaucoup mieux protégées
c'est une réalité depuis 2008 le
législateur national et européen à
multiplier les règles prudentielles qui
font qu'aujourd'hui les ratios de
solvabilité de liquidités
les garanties pour les Parisiens sont
plus importantes en Europe en France en
particulier qu'aux États-Unis toutefois
il y a peut-être des trous dans la
raquette européenne
en particulier quand il y a eu les
débats au Parlement et au Conseil
européen les banques régionales
allemandes essentiellement mais aussi
espagnol italienne ont échappé pour une
partie aux régulations très dures qui
sont imposées aux banques françaises et
donc là dessus c'est rajouter depuis 10
ans une fragmentation immense du marché
les états faisant l'implémentation de la
réglementation un peu à leur sauce et
tout ça fait qu'il y a une complexité
d'application très importante qui était
soulevée par la Cour des comptes
européennes récemment donc la question
c'est est-ce que vous pouvez imaginer
demander à admission européenne stress
test de toutes les banques en
particulier des banques régionales en
fait enfin votre premier arme monsieur
le ministre c'est la confiance alors
dans cette optique seriez-vous prêt
aussi à étudier
l'augmentation du seuil de garantie des
dépôts bancaires des épargnants et à ce
titre il faudrait évidemment demander à
ce que l'abondement du fonds de
résolution unique et la Caisse de
garantie des épargnants soit repoussés
au-delà de 2023 comme vous le savez à la
fin 2023 le fonds de résolution unique
en théorie doit cesser d'être abondé il
faut probablement
la parole est un